Should what do you think of drugs like prilosec or even taking tums?
So there I think they're they're one of the most AIDS
Light of drugs. There's a lot of danger. So I shouldn't say that there's there very dangerous light of drugs
Because why does a person go on prilosec? Why does a person take role aids or tums because they have indigestion because they have you know
Velching stomach acid up this off against they you know, they have stomach pain after eating. They have all this stomach pain
And 99% of the time that is from a deficiency in hydrochloric acid
So these drugs will remove all the hydrochloric acid or diminish the hydrochloric acid production in your stomach
Which is exactly the thing you don't want to do
Well, how could you say that? It takes my pain away. So it must be solving the problem
So when a person doesn't produce enough hydrochloric acid in their stomach and they eat food
That food will sit
Undigested or very partially digested in the stomach as a bolus of food
And it doesn't get moved into the small intestine at the rate that it should because it's only very partially
Digested because of the hypochloridory of the decreased hydrochloric acid
And then what stomach acid you do have could go up into the high point
The thunders of the stomach and you can belch it up most of time these people also have a concurrent
Hyatolherni issue so it could go into the esophagus it could erode the esophagus you could get esophageal
Alceration you could get stomach ulceration and a decreased hydrochloric acid production over time often leads to
Multiple things will lead to high helicobacter pylori overgrowth
So you don't have an h pylori infection which could cause an enormous amount of health conditions
You'll have a decrease intrinsic factor production. That's necessary for you to absorb B12. So you're going to have a B12 anemia issue
Um, and it causes ulceration so you end up with ulcers in your stomach ulcers in your esophagus
And then you take prilosecond it relieves your symptoms and you think you've solved the problem
But you're actually making it worse you're causing a more long term problem
You're pretty much guaranteed that you're going to have an h pylori infection
So when a person comes in the office and they've been a prilosecond for any length of time
It's pretty much a guarantee that they have an h pylori infection
The problem is h pyl doesn't always just stay in the stomach it doesn't stay in the intestine the track
So if you do an h pylori breath test it may show negative you do a stool sample test it might show negative too
So how do you have to identify it with other factors a blood test for h pylori
It's only a test if it's in the blood right now the problem is h pylori gets under the endothelial lighting of the arteries
And it's a major component of cardiovascular disease
So it is a major component is the number one cause of stomach cancer. It's a major component of other cancers
It could cause skin issues. It's it's just a bad player and everything and it is the most common bacterial infection
The planet
That's a statistic. I did not make up so it is a dangerous thing to be on these things again
Here you know again when you use medication or you use verbs or a natural methods of any kind that just cover up
A cause
You could you could make a problem a whole lot worse
So you can't just cover up a cause. Well, I take prilosecond makes my tummy feel better if I don't take it
I just can't stay at it. Well, you've got to fix the cause
This is just making it worse. So there it's a bad class of drugs my opinion